كان هنالك اعلان عن خطط لتوجيه ضربات هل
هنالك اعلان امريكي عن توجيه ضربات
لليمن ليس هناك زين اعلان رسمي لكن تحدثت
الان مع مع مسؤول دفاعي امريكي معني
بمنطقه الشرق الاوسط وقال لي التالي اولا
اكد انه بالفعل الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا قامت بشن ضربات على مواقع
لانصار الله الحوثيين في اليمن وهي انتهت
من شن هذه الضربات الضربات استهدفت اكثر
من موقع وهناك عمليه تقييم للاضرار
والمواقع التي جرى ضربها الضربات شنت زين
من قبل الطائرات ومن قبل الغواصات ومن قبل
السفن اي من ثلاث مصادر مختلفه لدى القوات
الامريكيه والبريطانيه وبحسب المسؤول
الدفاعي الامريكي قال للجزيره ان هناك
عمليه تقيييم في الوقت الراهن وبانت غار
رد فعل انصار الله الحوثيين على هذه
الهجمات التي كنا في جوها ابلغنا بها قبل
حصولها ولكن لم يكن كان محظور ان نتحدث
عنها ولكن واقع التسريبات اشارت الى ان
الولايات المتحده بالتعاون مع بريطانيا
سوف تتجه لتوجيه هذه الضربات بعد ان وجهت
تحذيرات شديده اللهجه لانصار الله
الحوثيين بتو بوقف هجمات تهم على عمليات
الشحن البحري في منطقه جنوب البحر الاحمر
وخليج عدن وحذرت من عواقب اذا استمر انصار
الله الحوثيون في هذه الهجمات وللتذكير
هذه الضربات التي اشرنا ان مسؤول دفاعي
امريكي اكد للجزيره حصولها بالفعل انها
تمت وانها اصابت اهدافها وانها حصلت من
الجو ومن القطع البحريه السفن وايضا من
الغواصات هي تات تي ردا على استمرار هجمات
الحوثيين في تلك المنطقه مسؤول عسكري
امريكي كان ابلغنا ايضا بان القوات
الامريكيه في المنطقه في حاله استنفار
وانها على اهبه الاستعلا للرد على اي
اعتداء كما قال من قبل الحوثيين في الزمان
والمكان المناسبين وبالتالي هذه الضربات
جاءت ترجمه لهذه التحذيرات للتذكير عمليا
جاءت بعد يومين من تمكن الولايات المتحده
من استصدار قرار في مجلس الامن الدولي
يندد بهجمات الحوثيين ويدعو الى وقفها
وبعد ما قالت الولايات المتحده انه بحلول
يوم امس الخميس وابتداء من ال من نوفمبر
كان انصار الله الحوثيين شنوا نحو 27
هجوما على اما على السفن التجاريه او على
خطوط الملاحه علما ان الولايات المتحده
حته حتى هذه اللحظه تقول انه لا معطيات
لديها بانها كانت مستهدفه بشكل مباشر اي
بان سفنها كانت مستهدفه بشكل مباشر في
الهجمات التي قام بها انصار الله الحوثيين
وهي تعتبر ان ما يحصل في جنوب البحر
الاحمر وما يقوم به الحوثيون هو منفصل
تماما عن الحرب في قطاع غزه واليوم امس
يوم الخميس قال وكرر المتحدث باسم
البنتاجون ب ان مساله ما وصفه بالنزاع في
غزه لا يزال حتى هذه اللحظه نجحت الاطراف
في احتوائه في غزه وبالتالي الولايات
المتحده تحاول ان تفصل ما بين هذين
المسارين بصرف النظر كيف يمكن ان ينظر له
انصار الله الحوثيون او المنطقه زين
وبالتالي نعيد ونؤكد نقلا عن مسؤول دفاعي
امريكي الولايات المتحده بالتعاون مع
بريطانيا قامت بشن مجموعه من الهجمات على
اهداف تابعه ل انصار الله الحوثيين في
اليمن مستخدمه السفن والطائرات الحربيه
وايضا ضربات من داخل المياه من قعر البحر
من الغواصات خصوصا ان الولايات المتحده
كانت اعلنت سابقا في ظل التوترات
الاقليميه على خلفيه الحرب الاسرائيليه
على غزه عن دخول الى منطقه الشرق الاوسط
غواصه من طراز اوهايو م مزوده بصواريخ
كروز لا نعرف اذا كانت لا لا تزال في
المنطقه لكن الولايات المتحده بطبيعه
الحال لديها قواعد منتشره في عموم المنطقه
لديها قاعده في جيبوتي قاعده لمونيه وايضا
لديها سفن حربيه من بينها حامله الطائرات
ايزنهاور والمجموعه الضاربه لها المرافقه
لها وهي عباره عن ثلاث سفن قباله ساحل
اليمن بالاضافه الى المدمرتين لابون ويسن
ايضا المتواجدين في تلك المنطقه زين